die foto's colors this is then in the
pepers wit caruso life where everyone
who watches the serious nose that the mouth
manager scientific
toppix i'm severely je thickness de flow
simulations and today it's time to
relapse
en this time will join to van windtunnel
tess en  hummingbird
typical i wanna know engine airplane
arievan a iphone is been design year
interested in doing keep pour flow en
dc pension we looked like preferably
before wiar designing the subject to so
so hoe je af en runs and virtual wind
to orchestra and optimizer design and they
were happy with the results
then we can proceed to bio die pike en treffers
simulating the partial distribution en
die aerodynamic forces is a lars copic
river wie zo leising die is wie wil
is preferably aswell studied and difficult
is rising simulated
what is it takes a  clean up you're
interested and even the flash and
intuitive
article b simulation millions and
millions of particles it is clearly in
possible t  o show the path for every one
of the great bay simulations af and even
more challenging to be zola's so
we keep choose what to his wife and
what not to show on the screen and in
this paper we can witness and no way of
wie zo  leising velocity and for the city
fields and this musicians and ebb and flow
patch maps
this is a mathematical transformation
where who creates is 4 and the set of four
winns of the sphere correspond to for
tex alliance and the evolution over time
however if in state of  oil pins
public and entire region on this 4s i
can see the north and south pole regions
hier wie op 10 voor text oops die
sportex to provide and accurate
representation of the between the
information within the simulation and
this is one of their cases where the
past tee of such a solution can also
be seen such great idea
loving it and we this weekend get better
understanding of the air flow
edges winx of hummingbird the weekend
also learn more
of projection sting nasal a  ircraft food
sets
cavello cap with incredible result
thomas in the paper piecing graph
conference is an incredible 4
dat type call it takes a few briliant
guys and several years of and believe
ably hard work well and friendly this is
not such a challenge for albert churn
hoe  was already the first author of death and
designing your smoke peper
just year ago that were reported on kies
de link incredible work and taking a
piece of mathematical siri and showing
remarkable applications of it in your
areas where i would think it doesn't
belong channel  the link is available in the
video discription both for this and the
previous works
make sure to have looked this lot's of
beautiful ebit mathematics to be that
there seems to be from another world
is the feeling younique xperience de
peper reports that the source code is  also
available
but he was unable to find the gap via
vai public implementation please let me
know
and well on this the video description
beolink cover there some c  hinian folio
generous support na see you next time
[Music]